this will be the worst movie review ever
why because we can't tell you anything
that happens in 10 Cloverfield Lane not
why this is cool or whether this is true
everyone i said here is dead not what's
on the other side of this door or why
this guy doesn't want it to get in we
can't tell you what's happening here or
why this house is glowing we also
probably shouldn't tell you why this
woman is chained up or why he thinks
she's safer there what are you gonna do
to me I'm going to keep you alive we
can't even tell you if it's a horror
flick or a sci-fi movie this after all
is a JJ Abrams picture and mystery is
everything telling you what happens
ruins the fun we can tell you one thing
though 10 Cloverfield Lane is the most
fun you'll have being confused all year
that is if your nerves can handle it